Politico has this report former
president Donald Trump offered an olive
branch to anheiser Bush on Tuesday
issuing a post on a social media
platform calling on conservatives to
drop their opposition to the besieged
Beer Company Trump wrote the budlight ad
was a mistake of epic proportions and
for that a very big price was paid but
anheiser bush is not a w company
anheiser bush is a great American brand
that perhaps deserves a second chance
what do you think perhaps instead we
should be going after those companies
that are looking to destroy America
Trump's post on Truth social represents
a major attempt at deescalation and a
long simmering feud between the
political movement the former president
leads and the mega Corporation since
April
2023 um Trump's message also comes as a
top Republican lobbyist for the company
is set to host a fundraiser for the
former president next month with some
tickets going at $10,000 each Jeff
Miller a close Confidant of former
former speaker Kevin McCarthy who built
his Washington Business during the Trump
years announced on X formally Twitter on
Tuesday that he will be hosting the
fundraiser all right um
let me be among the many here to say no
um hell no definitely not the Bud Light
boycott is not
ending there is no strategic reason to
end
it
um and it
it and Trump never even gave any
strategic argument for ending it what's
the Strategic like how does this help
strategically his argument is just he
they've had enough let's be nice to him
let's be nice to
this this International corporate
brand and by the way they are not an
American brand anheiser bush is a
foreign owned company it is not an
American company so this is a
foreign-owned
company
that that went woke and decided to push
transgenderism and in response
conservatives organized for the first
time ever in history to launch a
successful
boycott that actually
worked and now the argument is that we
should back off of
it just to be nice just to be nice to
this
International Mega Corporation because
we feel bad for
them that's the argument and uh
no now
does that mean that the boycott never
ends well sort of yes and no I think
that a lot of what we're dealing with as
I've said all along it's not just a
boycott for for budlight their problem
is that the boycott has
metastasized to an extent that it it's
like a terminal it's a terminal illness
now and they can never really get rid of
it um because the brand itself is just
seen as
lame right people will see it as it's
the gay beer that's how it's seen and no
amount of rebranding it does it doesn't
matter who tries to Rebrand it even
Donald Trump himself cannot can't can't
make it not lame
anymore like most guys if you see your
friend drink it a Bud Light you're going
to make fun of them now and that's never
you're gonna make jokes about it you're
never goingon to not make a joke about
it it's always going to be that way and
um so uh that that can't be stopped they
did that to themselves unfortunately for
them
but the official sort of boycott uh
could that end yeah it
could but you need to get an explicit
concession that's the way a boycott
works it's what the left does it's what
every successful boycott campaign in
history has done you get an explicit
concession and in this case that would
that could only be that would only need
to be um an apology that's it say we
shouldn't have done that we apologize
like literally two sentences would be
enough and and and I think most people
would say yeah it's still a gay beer I'm
not interested in it but but yeah okay
the boy cuts up fine you apologized
we'll move
on they have not apologized if your
house is feeling chilly right now you
may need to consider window replacement
I get it for most homeowners window
replacement isn't something they've ever
done before and it may be a bit of a
daunting task luckily there's a company
that will do the work for you Renewal by
Anderson is your One-Stop shop for
window design manufacturer and
installation Windows play a crucial role
in regulating indoor temperatures if you
notice a spike and you're heating or
cooling bills it may be due to
inefficient windows so don't put it off
any longer Renewal by Anderson offers
limited fully transferable and best in
the nation warranty coverage right now
Renewal by Anderson is offering a free
inhome consultation on quality energy
efficient Affordable Windows or patio
doors with special financing options Tex
Walsh to 200 300 for a free consultation
to save $375 off every window and
$775 off every door these savings won't
last long so be sure to check it out by
texting Walsh to 200 300 that's Walsh to
2000 300 texting privacy policy in terms
of conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrolls for recurring automated
text marketing messages messaging data
rates may apply reply stop to out go to
window appointment now.com for full
offer details they have not
apologized it's all they have to do and
they haven't and until they do the
boycott needs to remain if if we back
off take take the the uh our foot off
their throats without getting the
apology then we will have uh you know
rescued defeat from the jaws of
Victory it it it'll be one of the one of
the greatest conservative cultural
victories in recent times will turn into
one of our greatest self- owns in recent
time and there have been a lot of self-
owns unfortunately a lot more self- owns
than
victories where you're winning you've
done something you're successful and
then you just stop you simply stop for
no for no reason it's like well I'm
bored let's stop doing that what the
left have you notice the left never does
that they never do that like they don't
they don't they actually don't get bored
of
winning um and when they single somebody
out and they say this person this entity
uh is the
enemy and and all they they don't back
off they don't back off for
years
um at least until they get an apology
and even sometimes when they get an
apology they still don't
stop so to me this is very
simple budlight is a crappy product
first of all it's a forn company they
they did something they're reaping the
consequences of their own
choices and uh and and there's only one
simple thing they need to do
to uh have those consequences be be uh
you know in order order for it to stop
and and they haven't done that thing
they haven't given the
apology and
um but this goes beyond you know what
we're seeing now is it's not just ending
some people calling for the end of the
boycott it's like an actual attempt to
rehab budl light's brand for
them and that I'm definitely never going
to do even if I said okay the boycott we
should probably end the boycott cuz they
apologized I'm not going to try to help
them recover their own brand that's on
you you got to pick up the pieces I'm
not going to help you with
that why should we do
that is that is that is that uh is that
the how you win is that is that is that
being a fighter
now take your foot off the throat
without a concession and then help them
help them recover from the consequences
of their own actions
no no no hell no not going to happen uh
and that's it hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there